[Music]
about four years ago I guess we started
saying if we did do a video game this
time would be a totally hands-on project
so it started a while back with Trey
having this idea of making a
role-playing game around South Park we
produced an animatic that demonstrated
the game that Matt and Trey wanted to
make his the new kid leaves into the
Wizards humble there watch out for cat
dude they didn't do the traditional
hookup with a publisher do a licensing
deal they went out and started talking
to developers directly we were one of
those developers and so they stopped by
the studio they had these ideas for the
game they said can you make it look like
the show so we put together a prototype
for them and basically show them look we
can make one of your characters run
around in the world and it can look just
like the show when the current gens came
out we thought that they were finally
capable of doing a game that looked just
like the show that was sort of the thing
that excited us is you could sit there
and play the game and be walking around
the classroom are walking around
Cartman's backyard and if someone was to
walk in the room and watch you play the
game they would think you're watching an
episode of South Park it's been harder
than you'd think again South Park the
whole look of it it looks so crappy but
to make it looked at just that authentic
crappiness that you know in the early
days of production we would meet in the
conference room and we would show Matt
and Trey what the game was gonna look
like and we would have people from the
crew afterwards walk up to me and say is
that a new episode like I've never seen
that before so we know that we're on the
right track they'll have their guys over
at South Park animate it for us so that
we can see exactly what they want
because we learned early on that they're
very particular and they should be
awesome like you were gonna be a new kid
in the town because we wanted you to
have your own identity
I hate when a character talks for you
you know and I hate when I'm this
character and then I hear my character
go I'll get down there to planet take
care that's not what I would say that's
not how I would say
so you're the new kid everyone is
talking about what's your name
he doesn't talk health King he thinks
he's hot [ __ ] or something it is a new
adventure it's a new South Park
experience very much the same way bigger
Longer uncut was a brand-new movie it
wasn't just a bunch of episodes from
together so a lot of what we go over our
you know key elements of the franchise
use them in a new exciting way and not
just in every second of event access we
always lived in the show when the kids
were playing a game we had a lot of
different shows where they're playing
either FBI and cops or they're playing
like Lord of the Rings so they're just
playing this really simple game kind of
like capture the flag but it's basically
the stick let's take of truth whoever
has it controls the universe and it's
obviously just the game but in a normal
south part way everything gets escalated
to ridiculous proportions don't get it
too down for its power is too much
premiere mojo sir look at one of the
kind of visceral joys of playing video
game is getting powerful and when the
Zelda it's like you become a master of
the win like infamous you have
electricity's your weapon when sick of
truth we made it farts which is
surprised but it was really important
that you didn't just press a button
apartment it was analog no you need to
like feel it go out of your [ __ ]
allow me to demonstrate yeah that was a
million-to-one shot I sure hope the gold
kids in there who else request for the
silver kids but all for nothing this is
a video game it just can we can't do
everything so we're doing a story and
we're working on the characters and
we're trying to make it the South Park
thing but it's really such a bigger
thing at video games definitely a
humbling experience there a bear to get
your head around how to put one together
you can maybe hear can't fight shut up
Scott nobody cares anything
we're hoping that we make a game that's
worthy of the show I don't know but
that's what we're really trying to do I
hope we don't get it [ __ ] for on
GameSpot that's what I hope
now piss me off don't so that the games
how badly do they rape you
I shall make haste Cooper keep shut up
ma'am